[Musique]
bonsoir pour commencer je voudrais vous
amener faire un voyage un voyage en
corée du sud et plus particulièrement à
pyongyang
nous sommes en février 2018 en haut de
la piste de bobsleigh
c'est le ba ba de masculin il reste au
départ un seul équipage
trois manches ont déjà été courues
l'équipage qui étend aux équipages
canadiens
ils sont en tête après trois manches pas
de beaucoup
ils ont à peine cinq centièmes d'avancé
sur les allemands qui viennent de
décembre qui vont regarder leurs
adversaires en bas un kilomètre et demi
pour jouer un titre olympique
les canadiens sont prêts il démarre il
pousse c'est pas leur point fort et au
bout de cinquante mètres
ils ont déjà perdu tous leurs avantages
ils sont en retard un centième de retard
sur les allemands
vont-ils arriver à rattraper durant la
descente leur retard comme lors des
trois manches précédentes et il semble
que oui
à la sortie du virage 9 il repasse
devant l'écart est infime
un centième ex-aequo les deux bob sont
ex-aequo les deux bob sont champions
olympiques du matériel différent des
méthodes d'entraînement différent des
mentalités différentes et au final le
même résultat
le pilote canadien dirait en conférence
de presse je passe la ligne d'arrivée je
vois le tableau je vois ma place 1 je
sais que je suis champion olympique et
en levant les yeux dans la piste de
décélération je vois les allemands qui
sautent de joie et je me dis tiens ils
sont sympas ils sont contents pour moi
à cette époque il ne s'est pas encore
qu'ils sont tous les deux champions
olympiques
mais comment font ces sportifs pour
performer le jour j pour gérer leur
stress pour arriver à décupler leurs
capacités physiques et mentales à avoir
confiance en eux
ma propre quête de l'or olympique
commence en 1988 en lisant
journal au fil des pages je tombe sur un
article en forme de petites annonces
vous êtes grands vous est costaud vous
courrez vite voulait représenter la
france aux jeux olympiques en 1992
venez essayer le bobsleigh c'est comme
ça que quelques mois plus tard je me
retrouve en autriche
assis dans un bob une manette dans
chaque main le début d'une longue
histoire d'amour une longue histoire
d'amour ou à travers le globe
j'ai cherché la performance dans les
moindres détails la préparation physique
la préparation mentale la préparation du
mil du matériel le pilotage et parmi ses
clés la première qui m'a amené dans le
bobsleigh
ce sont des objectifs en entreprise
comme dans le sport on fonctionne par
cycles en bobsleigh quatre ans pourquoi
c'est la durée qui sépare deux jeux
olympiques
on part d'un résultat obtenu est ce
qu'on a été qualifiée est-ce qu'on a
gagné une médaille et ce qu'on a fait
10e 11e et on se projette
quatre ans plus tard qu'est ce qu'on
veut faire
j'ai fait 11e en 2018 à pyeongchang
je veux être champion olympique en 2022
à pékin et on sait par ces quatre années
en cycle annuel avec des échéances des
objectifs à moyen terme et en face on
regarde les moyens qu'on a
qu'ils soient financiers qu'ils soient
physiques qu'ils soient temporel on va
regarder nos points forts on va regarder
nos faiblesses les opportunités et les
menaces
on va regarder ce que fait la
concurrence on va regarder s'il n'y a
pas des nouveaux qui arrivent et qui a
même quelque chose auquel on n'a pas
pensé des outils qu'on utilise en
entreprise le soin de porter le smart
le smart votre objectif doit être smart
spécifiques mesurables atteignable
réaliste et temporellement défini et
dans le thé du temporellement défini on
touche là une des grandes différences
entre le monde de l'entreprise et le
monde du sport en sport on ne décide
jamais du moment où on va être jugés ce
sont les clubs les fédérations
nationales internationales
le comité international olympique qui
décide quand ont lieu les compétitions
et nous on doit s'adapter
je vous prends l'exemple des jeux
olympiques généralement là
ville est désigné sept ans avant et puis
plus on se rapproche de l'échéance
plus on aura de détails on va nous dire
à un moment les jeux auront lieu du 9 au
25 février
et puis une année avant le bob à 2
masculin le 16 et 17 février
et puis quelques mois on va nous dire la
première manche et la troisième manche à
20 heures la deuxième et la quatrième à
22 heures et on doit s'adapter ne pas
être prêts trop tôt ni trop tard et en
fait quand vous définissez votre
objectif vous devez savoir ce que vous
voulez vraiment est-ce que je peux aller
aux jeux olympiques est ce que je veux
être médaillés est-ce que vous pouvez
vraiment c'est à dire que c'est une
véritable introspection vous faut se
regarder en face
il faut vraiment définir cet objectif et
quand vos envies et vos moyens se
rejoignent alors vous allez pouvoir
déclencher la deuxième clé la motivation
la motivation c'est un équilibre entre
deux mondes le monde interne le monde
externe le plaisir la récompense
motivation intrinsèque extrinsèque un
peu comme la première fois quand vous
êtes jeune et que vous faites l'activité
une activité extrascolaire sportives
artistiques culturels généralement c'est
une motivation extrinsèque qui vous y
emmène faire comme être avec et c'est
grâce au plaisir que vous allez avoir à
pratiquer l'activité que vous allez
pouvoir la continuer sur le long terme
comme moi en 88 quand j'ai commencé le
bobsleigh
la motivation première c'était les jeux
olympiques de 1992 et il va falloir que
vous trouviez un pont entre ces deux
motivations
un jour le plaisir va être suffisant le
plaisir de piloter un bobsleigh le
plaisir de l'adrénaline d'un rendez vous
commercial ou d'un concours qui vous
passionne et une autre fois ça va être
une motivation extrinsèque une échéance
que vous vous devez de respecter et qui
va vous pousser à faire les choses ou un
collègue un coéquipier qui vous dit on
va pas craquer maintenant après tout ce
qu'on a fait mais il ya une autre
motivation qui est importante
une autre motivation qui et comment vous
intégrer vos propres motivations
personnes
elle à l'intérieur d'un objectif d'
équipe à une époque je manager un bob à
quatre avec un gros objectif qui était
d'être champion olympique
ça faisait 95% de la motivation mais
parmi ces quatre pour un sa motivation
personnelle c'était l'argent je gagne
des médailles je gagne de l'argent
un autre c'était la sécurité je gagne
des médailles
je m'assure un avenir parce que ça
m'ouvre les portes d'une école spéciale
pour les sportifs de haut niveau et à
l'issue de ma carrière sportive
j'aurai un métier qui me plaît un
troisième c'était la reconnaissance
médiatique je gagne des médailles je
passe à la télé je passe dans les
journaux et enfin le dernier c'était
juste par amour du sport et ça on le
retrouve dans les entreprises et ça
c'est un lien direct avec vos propres
valeurs
pourquoi vous levez vous chaque matin
que venez-vous chercher au travail que
venez-vous chercher dans votre école que
venez-vous chercher dans votre sport et
ça quand vous faites partie d'une équipe
en tant que manager il faudra aller
chercher ses motivations personnelles de
vos employés de vos équipiers et en tant
qu'équipier
il faudra trouver le moyen de les
exprimer parce qu'au final ce sont des
détails qui comptent
et quand vous avez un objectif est que
vous êtes motivé vous pouvez passer à
votre stratégie
qu'est ce que vous allez mettre en place
pour arriver au résultat pour moi dans
tout projet je distingue trois phases
une phase de préparation
une phase d'action une phase de bilan
est globalement plus objectifs nous
plaît et plus on a envie d'aller dans
l'action au risque parfois d'aller trop
vite et de faire des grosses erreurs qui
au final nous disent je suis plus motivé
j'y arriverai pas préparez vos plans
d'action préparez vos plans d'action il
faut que quand vous agissiez vous n'ayez
plus aucun doute
ça ne veut pas dire que votre plan doit
être parfait vous pouvez faire des
expérimentations au point fr des tests
mais il faut que dans votre esprit vous
sachiez consciemment ce que vous allez
faire en bob en fait c'est assez simple
puisqu'il
partir du moment où on pousse comme vous
l'avez eue avec les canadiens jusqu'à la
ligne d'arrivée
nous n'avons plus aucun moyen de
communiquer c'est à dire qu'à partir du
moment où on est au départ appartement
on commence à pousser chacun doit savoir
exactement ce qu'il a à faire jusqu'à la
ligne d'arrivée il faut exactement que
vous sachiez ce que vous avez à faire
et qu'est ce que ça va amener ça ça va
amener un engagement à 100 % quand vous
êtes dans l'action ne pensais pas au
résultat et ça peu importe la durée de
l'action que l'action dure 50 secondes
une minute comme en bobsleigh deux
heures comme un rendez vous commercial
ou plusieurs jours si vous êtes sur un
salon peu importe ce qui va être
important c'est la préparation vous avez
mis en place et plus vous aurez préparé
consciemment et plus vous pourrez
utiliser vos capacités physiques
mentales
les hearts qui les sauve qu'ils pour
obtenir un résultat qui correspond à vos
attentes
parlons-en justement des résultats
généralement ils sont de deux ordres
échec ou réussite alors l'échec a été
grandement étudier pourquoi parce que
généralement on travaille pas pour
échouer et ça nous fait jamais plaisir
d'échouer pour moi ce qui est important
dans l'échec c'est pas tellement
l'action telle qu'elle a été faite telle
qu'elle a été ratée parce que de toute
façon on pourra pas la changer
ce qui est important c'est comment elles
influent mentalement sur vos actions
prochaine vous êtes au départ votre
piste de bob un virage de virage trois
virages ça se passe bien
et puis virage 4 vous faites une erreur
est ce que ça vous empêche de bien
piloter au virage 5 au virage 6 est ce
que vous y pensez encore est ce qu'au
virage 6 vous êtes encore en train de
vous dire je trouve être le virage la
télé facile pourquoi je les ratés et du
coup vous raté le virage 5 6 et
peut-être jusqu'à l'arrivée où est-ce
que alors vous faites confiance vous
essayer d'appliquer au mieux le plan
jusqu'à l'arrivée et une fois l'arrivée
pour la descente d'après vous dites
pourquoi j'ai raté le virage 4 et à ce
moment là je vais faire autre chose
en 1994 je sortais plusieurs échecs
finalement je rate les jeux de 1992
je rate également ceux de 94 et je me
dis qu'est ce que je fais est-ce que je
continue ou est-ce que j'arrête et je
décide de continuer mais en changeant
des choses si je continue en faisant
exactement la même chose
j'aurai les mêmes résultats je change de
matériel je change d'entraîneur et ça
fonctionne plutôt bien
finalement j'y arrive si bien qu'en mars
en février 95 avec mon équipier un autre
éric on est médaillé aux championnats du
monde
la médaille n'a pas changé et elle était
belle c'était notre première médaille
nous n'avions jusqu'à présent jamais
gagné de médailles que ce soit en coupe
du monde aux championnats d'europe au
champion du monde alors forcément on est
content forcément on est content un an
après février 1993 ces 96 je suis aux
championnats du monde et là on fait 23e
c'est jamais facile de refaire une
médaille ça se joue à des détails mais
la 20 places de perdues ont fini la
saison et je me dis qu'est ce qui s'est
passé qu'est ce que je faisais il ya un
an que je n'ai pas fait cette année là
et en fait je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais oublié une chose primordiale
je n'avais pas fait le bilan du succès
on travaille pour réussir
et quand ça arrive c'est normal on
travaille pas pour échouer
hélas quand on réussit on a un peu les
endorphines les hormones qui montons à
champagne on à la médaille on a le le
diplôme on a le contrat et on se dit bah
c'est normal j'ai tellement bossé pour
ça et parfois on peut oublier de faire
le bilan du succès on peut oublier de
savoir pourquoi ça a marché cette fois
là surtout si les succès se répète que
ce soit en sport ou ailleurs et on
oublie les petits détails on oublie le
quart d'heure d'abdominaux qu'on faisait
à la fin et qu'on fait plus aujourd'hui
on se dire oh c'est pas grave c'est pas
ça qui fait la différence
eh bien si et depuis cette année là je
me suis juré et je me suis mis en place
une stratégie pour faire toujours le
bilan du succès à
trois questions la première c est ce que
cette fois là j'ai fait quelque chose de
différent par rapport à la fois d'après
pour voir exactement ce que je mets en
place
la deuxième est ce que j'ai utilisé des
compétences différentes pour voir si moi
je m'améliore pour être conscient de mes
amélioration est la troisième grâce aux
réponses précédentes c'est comment je
peux innover dans mon processus du
succès dans ma routine du succès innover
pour rester toujours motivés et depuis
ce jour là j'ai toujours fait ce bilan
du succès que ce soit seul ou en équipe
et justement l'équipe c'est la cinquième
clé que je vais vous présenter ce soir
parce que nous travaillons tous en
équipe en bobsleigh bien sûr c'est un
sport d'équipé on peut pas faire
autrement et c'est exactement pareil en
entreprise vous pouvez être bien sûr
dans une grande entreprise ou là il ya
une hiérarchie il ya des groupes il ya
des services mais même si vous êtes un
entrepreneur individuel aujourd'hui vous
travaillez en équipe vous travaillez en
équipe parce que votre équipe ce sera
vos clients ça sera vos fournisseurs et
ça sera également votre famille qui est
impliquée dans ce processus ou parfois
le soir ma vous devez faire la
comptabilité ou alors le week end et ça
c'est votre équipe est dans votre équipe
vous allez toujours trouvé des cultures
différentes des croyances différentes
qu'elles soient positives ou négatives
des systèmes éducatifs différents et
bien sûr des divergences d'opinion et il
faut que ce soit une force
il faut que se creusent et d'expériences
différentes vous servent et pour ça il
ya une chose qui est primordial c'est de
bâtir un langage commun
demain la première manche là il a 24
deuxième but ici vous devez vous douter
que je vous parle de bobsleigh
je vous en parle depuis tout à l'heure
ces deux termes leila 24 bits ici ce
sont des noms de patin on change les
patins sur un bobsleigh entre les
manches
ça dépend de la température de la glace
dépend du rayon des virages ça dépend de
l'hygrométrie
mais si vous connaissez pas
je suis obligé de vous expliquer quand
je parle à mes équipes je leur dis ça
ils comprennent tout de suite demain
vous intégrer mon équipe pour une raison
ou pour une autre
je suis obligé de vous de vous faire
part de ce langage commun je suis obligé
de vous intégrer
pensez-y pensez-y éviter quand vous
bâtissez votre équipe
évitez les formules du genre tu vois ce
que je veux dire vous m'avez compris et
puis ben si c'est un chef qui est un
petit peu dur on n'ose pas dire non et
puis dès qu'il est parti on se tourne
vers son voisin où il dit il a dit que
voilà on doit faire quoi penser à bâtir
ce langage commun pensez à bâtir et à
tirer la quintessence de votre équipe et
au final vous allez vous retrouver avec
ses clés alors ça ce sont les miennes je
les garde
vous avez peut-être en avoir d'autres en
avoir plus en avoir moins des
différentes elles vont être éparpillés
un petit peu partout et au gré de vos
expériences petit à petit elles vont
prendre leur place elles vont bouger et
il ya un moment où elles vont toutes
être au bon endroit
et quand vos valeurs vos objectifs et
vos moyens sont en phase alors tout est
possible
le 17 février 2014
je suis à sotchi en russie pour les jeux
olympiques je suis manager et entraîneur
de l'équipe suisse de bobsleigh et ce
jour-là 26 ans après mes débuts
mon équipe est devenue championne
olympique
et quand le bob passe la ligne que la
médaille devient réalité
je me suis rendu compte d'une chose bien
sûr la médaille le symbole de la
réussite sportive elle est là elle est
bien mais autre chose et là aussi c'est
tout le parcours que j'ai dû faire pour
en arriver là tout ce que j'ai dû faire
depuis 1986 88
pour arriver à ce résultat la la
médaille est importante bien sûr mais le
parcours
avec tous ces apprentissages l'est tout
autant alors mesdames messieurs ce soir
dans votre quête
sur le chemin qui vous mènera à
l'objectif que vous êtes fixé faites en
sorte que ce soit une source
d'accomplissement
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]